I wanted to continue talking
about property rights and
the environment and also
to talk more about public lands and
natural resource management problems.
And I wanted to pick up on some of the
questions that were raised on Tuesday.
Uh,
with respect to the property regime that
was created by the state of New York in
the Adirondack Park.
And,
you know,
part of the problem with,
uh,
encouraging people to behave in
accordance with law is their perception of
legitimacy or the purpose of the law.
You know,
how consistent are there values with the
values that are embedded in law has a
mission statement.
So what factors,
can you imagine a would influence your
perception of the legitimacy of a new
regulation?
You know,
one thing might be a,
the way that you might have been allowed
to participate or were excluded from
the decision making process to
set up the new rule to begin with.
Uh,
another might be resistance,
a annoyance,
uh,
or a perception of immorality that,
some other group or individual
is imposing their values on you.
So one way to think about the history
of the Adirondack park is that prior to
1973,
uh,
the,
the local governments
really had authority to,
to control land use.
Uh,
and after the passage of the law,
the next day,
all of a sudden they did not
have that authority anymore.
And the rights of private
landowners were radically reduced.
So they went from a condition of being
rather free to develop their land as they
pleased to one where they really had to
understand the technical nature of law
as well as where they
were on this map that,
uh,
had had a,
the force of law,
let's zone did they fall within a,
and the argument is also the perception
of legitimacy is also a curiously tied
to science.
Uh,
and what's the relationship then
between science and law so that,
uh,
if,
this law was designed in a way to
prevent damage from being incurred by new
development.
Uh,
then how certain are these experts
sitting inside the government agency,
uh,
that the damage is likely to occur?
You know,
what's the,
what is the likelihood?
Are they thinking about it formally in,
in terms of probabilities of damages and
magnitudes a distribution of damages?
How are they thinking about,
uh,
the need to bring evidence data and
a strong science to questions about,
uh,
damage that supposedly justified these
new restrictions on their liberty and
what,
uh,
would,
population,
uh,
that,
is,
is low and income a relatively low,
uh,
in educational attainment compared
to other parts in New York?
You know,
what's their capacity to
challenge these new regulations?
I mean,
do they had the,
uh,
do they have the ability to,
or the or the money to hire a cologists
or soil scientists or atmospheric
scientists,
water quality experts to challenge the
government's claim that if they build the
way they want to,
that,
uh,
damage is going to occur.
Also the idea of compensation.
We'll talk more about that.
Uh,
especially next week when we think about
climate change in the coastal zone and
what that means for all the property
owners and the trillions of dollars of
property value,
uh,
in the coastal zone.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
under what kinds of conditions,
to do land,
uh,
can they expect compensation for loss
and property value that's associated with
these new laws and regulations.
And I want to also mention the work,
uh,
of Max Vapor.
Max Faber was a social scientist in
the early part of the 20th century,
a latter part of the 19th century.
And he wrote about the idea of
authority and a I mentioned on Tuesday,
and I want to reinforce this idea that
that a property is a form of authority.
It basically is,
is a social relationship among
those who are given rights,
uh,
and those who are obliged
to follow those rights to,
to not invade those rights in a way a
right is a kind of a sphere of liberty.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what happened in the
Adirondacks is that a,
this fear of liberty was
reduced and it was reduced,
uh,
largely based on the claim of the
government and a environmental experts.
Uh,
that damage was occurring from new
development and that it should be stopped.
Now when you think about the
sources of legitimacy in law,
if you look,
go back into political and social theory,
you'll find really a three dominant
sources that are commonly mentioned.
You know,
one is the authority,
the authority of the state,
uh,
to,
to pass law,
uh,
their,
their sovereign authority.
Uh,
the state meaning any level of government,
uh,
another would be a charisma.
Uh,
the,
the authority that is committed by a,
a charismatic leader,
perhaps a religious leader.
Uh,
and the third that I find to be most
relevant to this discussion today is the
idea of tradition.
Uh,
so that the idea that,
uh,
you know,
there's been a traditional pattern of
behavior that has been acceptable in a
society.
We've always been allowed to
sell off five acres a year or a,
we've been able to develop when we,
when we,
uh,
wanted to.
And now you're telling
us that we can't do that.
So possession is often thought of
as being nine tenths of the law.
And I'm sure you've heard
that phrase well that,
that uh,
this idea that tradition
and custom really underlie,
uh,
the,
the sense of legitimacy
is really quite important.
So when people have rights taken away,
they appeal to a,
their customary pattern of behavior
that their traditional rights.
You might also think about theories and
politics about the origin of property.
You know,
how,
how is,
uh,
property drived?
What's its source?
Well,
John Locke,
uh,
argued that a one source was God.
God gave humans a the right to
expropriate resources from the land.
Another is labor.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you,
you probably have heard about deluxe
labor theory so that if you invest in your
Labor in,
in,
uh,
improving land,
then you are justified in
claiming ownership to the
fruits of that improvement.
Another,
his inheritance in Rousseau roped,
uh,
extensively about the
unfairness of inheritance laws,
uh,
and argued that inheritance allowing,
the next generation to take the
property from the previous one,
that inherent inheritance,
how it really is the,
uh,
the fundamental origin
of inequality in society.
Another is scarcity.
So you can imagine yourself being that
alone on an island as a Robinson Crusoe
was a,
so that there's really no need
for definition of property rights.
Uh,
basically there was no ma,
no there,
there may have been
conditions of scarcity,
but,
uh,
there,
there was no need to set up rules about
who could get access to the scarce
resources so that there are other,
uh,
origins as well,
including regulation.
And I think I'm a,
I'm,
I'm becoming a fascinated
by the relationship,
uh,
between,
the act of regulation and the
creation of new property rights.
So you might think about,
uh,
what we all now are concerned
about relative to climate
change is being stalled
out because we can't agree on a regulation
to cap the amount of carbon that
would be allowed to be
admitted to the atmosphere.
So once that cap is established,
that's going to set the stage for the
evolution of markets and trading schemes,
uh,
among groups around the world so that,
property rights are often created
by regulation in ways that are not,
uh,
generally,
proceed on other ideas that,
uh,
you know,
when government regulates and creates
permits or a demands that you come and you
get a license,
whether it's a driver's
license or a license to use a,
a new pesticide,
uh,
whatever it is.
If you're required to get a permit,
uh,
then that permit,
automatically has value and
a developers will often,
uh,
by land,
and then try to get approval,
uh,
to develop that land with no anticipation
that they are going to actually carry
through the development.
Uh,
but they're going to sell that,
right?
They're going to sell the
land along with the permit,
uh,
so that they will basically accrue
the increase in property value that's
associated with a new permit.
And we saw on the atomic weapons
testing area and also related to a,
uh,
private,
trade secrecy.
That secrecy creates property rights.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
creates great value in the secret.
And,
uh,
there is often a black market
in the trade of secrets.
So there are variety of different kinds
of property you're most familiar with
the idea of private property
and public property.
Uh,
but there's also an idea in the literature
about the comments so that there are
these areas,
uh,
of the environment or the universe of
that might be thought of as a Commons
where the property rights
are really not well defined.
And Garrett harden a wrote a piece in
1968 called the tragedy of the Commons.
If you haven't read it,
I commend it to you.
And it was a piece that argued that if
you have common land with an a defined
rights to it,
then people are going to try
to take advantage of that land.
And he used the example of a past year
in Great Britain where everybody wanted
to graze their sheep on the past year.
Well,
that's fine.
Uh,
until you get a critical mass,
a sheep on the past year,
and all of a sudden you lose the capacity
of the landscape to regenerate the
grasses,
uh,
eventually as more and more people
come in and to graze their sheep,
uh,
than the,
the resources going to
be degraded and lost.
And he was using that as an argument to
justify a regulation or a new form of
control over who would have
access to the common lands.
Uh,
we also think about public lands,
I think in,
in a very simplistic way.
And the,
the,
uh,
the rest of this lecture is going to
focus on public lands and also the ways
that a,
the very,
very different ways that rights
can be allocated to public lands.
Uh,
and the implications of that for
sustainable resource management.
And also the fact that,
you know,
as you look out across the landscape
where you think about a nation or any,
uh,
territory,
you're going to have a pretty,
uh,
pretty complex hybrid among these
different forms of private property.
And you know,
somebody who might think of
themselves as a pursuing a career to,
uh,
manage environmental quality.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm going to make an argument that,
uh,
you have very little capacity to manage
an environmental problem unless you
understand with great clarity,
uh,
the relationships that are created
by these hybrid property systems.
So once you understand the
property regime in an area,
you have a much higher
capacity to manage it.
Uh,
and especially next week we'll be talking
more about the fifth amendment to the
Constitution,
nor shall private property be taken for
public use without just compensation.
Uh,
that,
uh,
presented a,
an opportunity for courts through
the 20th century to the present,
uh,
to,
debate,
uh,
where the threshold is.
What's an acceptable limit on government
authority to take private property and
when do they cross that threshold and
therefore have to compensate the private
land owner,
uh,
for taking away those rights.
Uh,
so what's justifiable public use?
This has been heavily
debated in the courts.
Uh,
what government appropriation
becomes a taking a,
when has it been when
his land been rendered,
valueless,
uh,
and should government's regulation
of private property be restricted.
So let's,
uh,
kind of drop some of these ideas
down on to the Adirondack park.
And I mentioned that it's a 6 million
acre track of land and you know,
we could have used a different
park or a different area.
Uh,
we could have used Yellowstone,
I'll use a couple of examples in
a few moments about Yellowstone,
but in this area you have
6 million acres of land.
And about roughly 50% of
it is privately owned.
Uh,
and the other 50% is publicly owned
and a was as I described on Tuesday,
the,
the Adirondack Mountain Reserve.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
it was forest preserve land,
that the constitution of New York protects
against any sort of timber harvesting
and he sort of structural development
unless that development is necessary to
protect that land on the part
of the state of New York.
Uh,
and this land has been
classified under this statute,
uh,
that was adopted in 1973.
The Adirondack Park Agency statute
into a variety of different categories,
including wilderness and
the orange at the top.
So about 18% of the area,
20% of the area now has been
designated as wilderness.
Uh,
using a standard that is more rigorous
than the federal wilderness designation,
uh,
standard,
which requires only 5,000 acres for
a new wilderness area to be created.
There are nearly 20 separate wilderness
areas in the Adirondacks right now and
the,
uh,
the minimum size requirement
to create them as 10,000 acres.
So it's double the
federal standard in the,
uh,
in the total area that's required.
They also have primitive areas.
Primitive areas are like wilderness,
except that they might have
certain facilities on the interior,
uh,
perhaps roadways,
perhaps fire towers,
perhaps ranger street stations,
maybe,
uh,
some electric lines.
And these primitive areas
constituted a rather small percent.
Another areas and experimental area that
I'll show you a slide of an a moment
called a canoer area.
And then about 22.4% of the,
uh,
this public land,
22.4% of 3 million acres,
uh,
is classified as wild forest.
So just think about this for a moment.
This is the largest track of intact
forest in the eastern United States.
Uh,
it's extremely rich and
biological diversity and it
has had this century long,
longer than a century,
a system of control,
uh,
that,
is embedded in the constitution
of the state of New York.
And then further refined by this
Adirondack park agency statute,
uh,
into these different categories that
allow very different and specific kinds of
uses.
Now think about the definition
of wilderness for just a moment.
This is contained in the wilderness
act of 1964 a wilderness.
In contrast with those areas where man
in his own words dominate the landscape
is hereby recognized as an area where
the earth and its community of life or
untrammeled by man,
we're man himself as a visitor
who does not remain well.
This is a very interesting definition.
It implies that a human
presence or any human influence,
uh,
in this area is not tolerable.
So that a,
the Adirondacks,
uh,
again,
with a,
you know,
roughly,
uh,
a million,
million a quarter acres,
a designated wilderness offers many,
many opportunities to,
uh,
seek solitude and get off
on your own and test your,
your physical and,
and,
uh,
personal skills.
But what's quite interesting about it
is that people within these designated
areas are really drawn to very,
a very small percentage of the area.
People are drawn to the mountain peaks.
And one reason why this,
uh,
this mountain peak is,
is bald,
is because people have,
have hiked to the summit,
uh,
so often.
And the soils on the summit's a of
peaks throughout New England are very
shallow.
So they're very vulnerable with a,
if the vegetation that,
uh,
this young man is about to jump on,
if that vegetation is lost,
the soil that it sits on will be lost,
uh,
and it will erode down to bedrock and
thereby will never have a opportunity to
support additional vegetation
if it kind of interesting.
Uh,
oh,
I'll show you a,
uh,
a clear cut,
that,
uh,
in,
in a western forests in just a moment.
Now,
I want you to start also think about,
uh,
goals that people have for going
into wilderness in different areas.
And,
uh,
I just,
was looking at the cost of taking a trip
and a climbing Mount Everest in Nepal.
And for a single climber,
it's $25,000.
Uh,
for two people,
it's 40,000.
And for seven people at $70,000.
It was kind of interesting that,
uh,
the governments in,
in different parts of the world are,
are,
are thinking about the right to climb,
uh,
and the value of the right to climb.
Uh,
at the same time,
they're thinking about the costs that
the government might incur if something
goes wrong on those trips.
And they have to,
they have to fund a,
uh,
a rescue effort.
By the way,
uh,
Mount Everest is about
29,000 feet in elevation a,
but Denali in Alaska is about
20,000 feet in elevation.
So if you're willing to give
up that last 9,000 feet,
uh,
you can go to the top
of Denali for only $200.
By the way,
there are also,
uh,
many parts of,
of,
uh,
the world were climbing.
Parties are required to post a bond,
a bond that would cover the total cost of,
of,
uh,
an expedition to,
to go in and rescue them in the case.
It's something goes wrong.
Now in the Adirondacks.
Uh,
another way to think
about wilderness or my,
my view of,
of wilderness,
uh,
was,
was shifted dramatically.
And just as an aside,
when I,
when I was working,
uh,
in the Adirondack park when I was younger,
my responsibility was to manage the
policy for these wilderness lands.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
I faced constant,
tension and an argument debate about,
uh,
what user groups should be
allowed access into which areas.
And,
uh,
if new wilderness area
was being designated,
people would fight,
tick to keep the roads open,
to keep the,
uh,
a ranger cabins open to,
to basically maintain these traditional
or customary patterns of use.
So one thing that I
was struck by was this,
that sits on the top of whiteface
mountain white face was the site of,
is the site of the Olympic,
uh,
training,
downhill facilities.
And,
uh,
the,
it's also a,
a,
a national weather station that started
to collect data during the 1970s and
early 1980s.
The demonstrated that,
uh,
we were experiencing significant
changes in the atmosphere.
Uh,
we were experiencing a increases in,
in software and,
and,
uh,
sulfur dioxide and
nitrogen oxides that we're,
we're producing sulfuric and
nitric acids and these acids.
We're having an effect on,
uh,
a force in the Adirondacks and
shifting the biological diversity,
particularly a high elevations in
ways that really were not anticipated.
Why high elevations
and not low elevations?
Well,
it turns out that nobody had really
thought about the contribution of,
of fog and clouds that cluster around
mountain peaks as a creating a kind of an
intense and chronic
exposure to the plants,
uh,
or,
or animals that live in those areas.
So that the,
uh,
the red spruce decline in the
Adirondacks is now now related to this.
The Red Spruce,
uh,
become susceptible to
a variety of different,
uh,
kinds of insects in,
in response to their,
their exposure to increased acidity
paradox of wilderness.
And thinking about how to manage it,
uh,
is that,
you know,
we tend to think about
it as nature in the wild,
but it really is a social construction.
Uh,
and there's a very strong
association with liberty.
And,
and the paradox is that if you're
managing or wilderness area,
then you have to think carefully
about what intensity of human use,
uh,
it could sustain and still maintain
its character and many people,
uh,
and I am included think that,
when I go into a wild area,
I'm not really interested in signing up
at a ranger station and getting a permit
to go into a wilderness and being told
where I can camp and where I can't camp.
And that kind of defeats the purpose of,
in my mind,
of what wildness is.
So what's the origin of that worry?
Well,
it's basically the Association of
wildness with personal freedom,
uh,
but obviously is more and
more people want to climb a,
a Denali or Mt.
Everest or go into the high
peaks of the Adirondacks.
It raises the question,
I know of carrying capacity,
you know,
what is a,
what's inappropriate limit.
So the Adirondack Park Agency face this
question with respect to many different
ecosystems that it had the
responsibility under this law to,
to manage.
Uh,
there are some 2000 different
islands on a more than a thousand,
uh,
lakes and ponds in the Adirondacks.
And these tend to be pretty small,
a couple of acres in size.
They also tend to be a,
uh,
basically just,
granitic bedrock,
uh,
that,
has very shallow soils.
So that new development
on these islands was,
was quite highly restricted and islands
are extremely from a developer's
perspective and also from,
from a,
uh,
the perspective of a recreational sites.
So that a,
you mean if,
if you were canoeing down this lake in
the Adirondacks and you saw one of these
islands,
you probably would want to canoe
over to one and explore it or,
or,
or camp on it.
And the state is,
has built campsites on this,
on these islands.
So there are always questions about,
you know,
how much development and
what kind can it sustain,
how much recreational in,
in,
uh,
intensity can it sustain,
without damage.
In this case,
one of the key questions
would be sewage disposal.
As I was mentioning with the camp
Sagamore slide back on Tuesday.
So,
uh,
the,
the foot group here,
uh,
when I was working with foot,
as an advisor,
uh,
some years ago,
the foot crew,
uh,
went up to the Adirondacks and I
helped them lay out trails through the
Adirondacks,
uh,
that,
seemed like they were suitable.
Uh,
but it was quite curious because the,
the,
the park,
uh,
became much more concerned about
loss of soil on the peaks and,
uh,
the,
the roots.
And they decided that don't,
one approach was going to be to
limit the size of the parties.
I can't remember the size of what,
you know,
some of you probably went on foot,
anybody in the room,
what's the,
uh,
party size and in foot?
Yes,
about 10 while this party size has
been now restricted to eight in the
Adirondacks,
which basically meant that the foot was
going to keep using the area that it
would have to reduce its party size
so that they were kind of interesting
questions about cost efficiency and uh,
the program effectiveness
related to party size and uh,
many logistical questions so that
they decided to back out and,
and a to move to two other sites.
So this idea that,
uh,
for any wilderness area you would have
both a kind of a physical biological idea
of what it's carrying capacity might be.
But,
uh,
there,
there was also a very interesting
literature on the psychology of wilderness
that,
uh,
has been pioneered by the forest service,
about what people expect.
What do people want?
Do they want to see people when
they go back into a remote areas?
And most people would presume
that the answer would be no.
But then if you look at the,
uh,
the pattern of wilderness use and national
park use in our country and pretty
much around the world,
what you see is that a wilderness is a
playground for a social cohesion in a
way.
I mean,
families go back,
friends go back into a remote areas
so that very few people go into a very
remote areas alone.
I find that to be kind
of interesting so that,
that,
uh,
it becomes a,
it becomes an outdoor,
a opportunity for,
uh,
a socialization.
You know,
another kind of write that,
uh,
you might not think about is this a right
to use motor vehicles and the right of
access.
And if you allow a float
plane operators in,
in a national park or our wilderness area,
you are creating a,
a variety of management headaches.
Now,
float planes are not
allowed in wilderness areas.
And,
uh,
when we decided we were
going to close off a,
a large number of lakes,
uh,
to,
to a motor vehicle access either
by car or use of boats or,
or,
uh,
jet skis or,
or access by my aircraft.
You can imagine the Howells that went up
because people had gone onto the public
land as they have in many remote
parts of the u s and including,
uh,
in,
large tracks of,
of uh,
uh,
large areas of Alaska.
And they have built these camps,
uh,
on public land and they claim that
they've been using this camp for the past
couple of decades.
That there they're a daddy use that camp
and to that they really have a right to
continue access and continue use.
Well,
the,
uh,
strength of the conflict is really
driven by what options they've got.
And,
and luckily in the Adirondacks,
remember you've got this
wilderness category,
but you've got these
other categories as well.
We're motor vehicles are allowed and
they would have similar opportunities to,
to fly into two other lakes so that the,
the politics was managed.
Uh,
basically because of the existence of,
of alternative sites,
still those people that had gone back
to their camps and invested in building
camps and these camps,
some of these camps were actually quite,
quite nice.
Uh,
they had stoves,
they had propane gas stoves,
they had heaters,
and they had a refrigerators.
So that,
uh,
you know,
these were more than modest little sites.
The evolution of small motorized vehicles
is also created a very significant
management headache so that,
uh,
and whether or not it's
a jet jet ski or a,
an ATV.
The forest service,
the park service and the
bureau of land management,
a nature conservancy,
anybody who manages a large track of land,
uh,
in the United States today,
he's faced with a worrying and
trying to figure out how to,
how to manage access by these vehicles.
They're fast,
they're light.
Uh,
they can,
uh,
basically a,
a zip around and escape,
uh,
rangers so that the amount of damage
to these can cause is really quite,
quite,
uh,
interesting.
And many of the,
many of the users are also interested in,
uh,
and hunting and,
the ATVs provide a,
basically a vehicular method to,
uh,
to,
to pull game out of a remote areas.
The shot of,
of a snowmobiles in west Yellowstone
is also interesting to me.
West Yellowstone,
uh,
during the wintertime in periods of peak
usage by snowmobiles where they have
conventions of thousands of
snowmobiles in west Yellowstone,
the particulate and,
and,
uh,
ozone air quality is,
often worse than it is in New
York City or it is in Los Angeles.
So that there is a,
there has been an improvement in the
emissions from the smaller engines.
Uh,
but,
uh,
still they are significantly
less efficient than,
than our a motor vehicle engines,
excuse me,
such as a cars.
Uh,
I also wanted to mention that,
that,
uh,
the Adirondacks has a bunch of scientific
experiments and one of the values of,
of wilderness is,
is to provide an environment where
scientific experiments can take place.
And the,
the idea that,
uh,
the ecology and the chemistry of a
Adirondack ecosystems is being transformed
by,
by our coal burning behavior in the
Midwestern part of the United States.
So that the,
uh,
the emissions from the Midwest
sweep up the Ohio valley,
uh,
they sweep into Pennsylvania and,
and the New York state.
And that,
that's really one of the
predominant sources of,
of uh,
the,
the acid aerosols here
and now these lakes are,
are basically a barren
of native strains of,
of trout.
And that's primarily because they're,
they're highly dependent upon a,
on the acidity level,
not getting a above or the,
uh,
the Ph not getting below a certain level.
In this case,
uh,
a variety of different
experiments had been,
uh,
attempted including Liming
lakes when I was there.
We would fix buckets,
these really large buckets of lime and
helicopters would pick up the buckets and
drop the lime over the lakes in an,
in an attempt to,
uh,
to buffer the acidity and make it more
suitable for the native strains of trout.
Eventually this became so
cumbersome and they realize that,
uh,
it would cost way too much to apply
this broadly across different lakes and
ponds that instead they thought about
genetic modification of fish to increase
their tolerance so that
they're now a variety of,
of different species of trout that had
been genetically engineered to make them
more tolerant.
So that when I mentioned earlier that,
um,
you know,
my perception of,
of,
uh,
you know,
what wilderness is,
was transformed by,
uh,
the atmospheric testing that took
place on the top of Whiteface Mountain.
Now this is what I meant.
Uh,
also if you go back to some of
the old growth timber in the park,
a timber that's been there for at least,
uh,
a,
say 50 or 60 years.
Uh,
and if you did a,
a,
a core,
it's,
in other words,
if you took a a screw and you,
you,
uh,
you cord into the tree and you pulled
out a core of wood all the way from the
center of the tree,
you could test back in
time and have a chemical,
uh,
replication of what was
in the air during a,
uh,
different years.
Uh,
so one of the interesting things that
you could find is the period between 1945
in 1963,
which was the atomic weapons testing era.
You would find the radionuclides in some
species of timber that are of that age
up there.
So that in some way they become a,
a,
a chronicle of past atmospheric quality,
the Olympic training
facility and the Adirondacks.
Also a presented many different
kinds of property rights questions.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
the downhill ski facility on the
top of which is the weather station.
And this is the long been the site of,
of uh,
uh,
national and international ski racing,
competitions.
And there was a,
a very curious debate about,
because this is on Adirondack forest
preserve land and this facility was not
allowed to be built,
uh,
until the legislature passed
on two successive occasions,
an amendment to the New
York state constitution.
It's quite interesting so
that no development remember,
could be built on forest preserve lands,
uh,
unless there was a
constitutional amendment that
required this two successive,
uh,
actions on the part of the legislature.
So they did this,
but they also constrain the
trail with a to 80 feet.
Well,
the International Olympic Committee said
we can't have a downhill ski race on a
trail that's only 80 feet.
And with our ratios are
likely to go speeds of 80,
90,
a hundred miles an hour
and the steepest areas,
and we've got to do something about that.
We want to cut [inaudible]
swaths in the landscape that are,
I mean,
one case in order to cut one that
was about a hundred yards in width,
uh,
in the argument of safety.
Well,
the,
uh,
the eventual s the eventual solution was,
no,
you can't cut the trail is up to that
level because that would be a violation of
the constitution.
Uh,
but instead you can install
netting on the sides of the trails.
So the,
the skiers go out of control.
They'll become entangled in the
nets and they won't hit the trees.
Kind of a very interesting debate between
the environmentalist's on the one hand
and those that are promoting the value of,
of the Olympics and the
international comradery and,
uh,
good spirits that it generates and those
concerned about the health and safety,
uh,
of the ski racers.
Another facility that,
uh,
I had the opportunity to,
manage the permit issuance
for was the ski jump facility.
I don't know,
are any of you a ski jumpers?
Uh,
probably not here.
But,
uh,
when I taught at Dartmouth,
I had a number of ski jumpers in the,
in my classes.
And the,
these facilities are a,
it's a 90 meter ski jump,
meaning that,
uh,
if you take off from the end,
the maximum flight distance
Safelite distances,
uh,
roughly 90 meters,
and then the 70 meter jump has next to it.
And a,
these were highly contested because they
are the tallest structures now between
Albany,
New York and Montreal,
and they lie immediately adjacent
to the high peaks wilderness area.
So the question posed
to the park agency was,
well,
what kind of a effect would
these towers have on the,
the,
the wilderness character
of the high peaks region?
And the Olympic organizing
committee loved the idea.
Uh,
they thought that these towers
would become a symbolic of,
of,
uh,
lake placid and the Adirondacks being a
winter sports capital and training site
for the nation.
Uh,
but the environmentalist's,
uh,
threatened to sue.
They argued that this
should not be allowed,
uh,
that,
it is,
uh,
clear,
intrusion into the wilderness
character of the area.
And eventually the,
the state of New York decided that,
uh,
these towers should be
built or rather obviously,
and,
uh,
despite the,
the,
uh,
requirement of the National
Environmental Policy Act,
uh,
that,
demands that whenever federal
funds are being expended,
that alternative sites
have to be explored.
And,
uh,
so that in this case that meant well,
could you find an alternative site where
you didn't have to build a 350 foot
tower?
And the answer was yes.
Uh,
several alternatives existed that
would even be lower in costs.
And here's an example,
uh,
from,
from Europe of how many European
communities such as a Garmisch part and
character in Innsbrook.
And,
uh,
the,
jumps in Sweden and Norway,
they're built into the hillside.
So basically the problem is it's a,
an engineering problem of sorts.
You know,
that you have a very specific
profile that is necessary in the,
in the jump design.
Uh,
and you also have a specific profile
in the landing hill that is required.
It has to be precise,
otherwise the jumpers are,
are,
are endanger.
Also they need to point north because,
uh,
if,
if the sun comes down
and beats on the track,
you'll,
it'll make the a,
it can change the consistency of the snow
on the end run and make it unfair for
say,
a jumper that's going later in the day.
Uh,
they also have to a point in a direction
that is opposite a prevailing winds,
uh,
because when a jumper goes off the jump,
you don't want them blowing around so
that they have very specific site design
criteria.
However,
one was found in lake placid and National
Environmental Policy Act demanded that
that site be considered.
Uh,
and uh,
it was a eventually rejected
by the state of New York,
which resulted in the
building of that tower.
No.
One additional example of an intrusion
into wilderness that was being proposed
was the mount van Hoven Berg,
a cross country ski run.
And this is a,
this is now a terrific run.
Uh,
and they have a 50
kilometer races that are,
are,
uh,
held in the Olympics.
And,
uh,
when this was proposed,
people thought,
well,
you know,
uh,
these trills really don't need to be a,
anything that,
perhaps wider than,
uh,
this table on the top of the podium here.
And,
and it turned out that they
had to be a quite a bit wider.
They needed to motorized
vehicles that could,
could,
uh,
move through and they could
plow the snow up the way that I,
a snowcat Woodard,
a ski area,
and then San attract behind them for,
for the racers to follow.
Uh,
so the question became,
well,
should we allow,
uh,
should we allow motorized access,
in wilderness areas to,
to facilitate the
development of this facility?
And the answer was no.
Uh,
the government,
uh,
the state of New York
decided that instead,
uh,
there was an adjacent track of
land that could easily be used and,
uh,
they would even have
to use less land area,
uh,
and,
cut down fewer trees if
they would use bridges.
The way that to many of the
European communities that
have these facilities have
done,
uh,
that,
the cross the trails so that a wooden
bridge crosses the trail so that you don't
have interference.
Uh,
as a,
as the race progresses,
a wilderness often creates additional
debates about the kind of interior
management that should occur.
Should you have facilities
on the interior,
uh,
such as a ranger station,
should arrange your live on
the interior or should a,
the rangers be roving through the area.
Very interesting questions,
uh,
related to emergency response time.
And,
and the,
uh,
the access by helicopter obviously
reduces that response time.
Uh,
and the,
the,
uh,
advent of,
wireless communications makes it,
makes it much easier to,
to get injured people out of these areas.
Uh,
but you know,
every year,
uh,
several people will die in the
Adirondacks in the middle of the winter.
It's a,
it's famous for,
for its storms where they start out at a,
say,
37 degrees and it's raining,
and then,
uh,
by,
maybe eight or 10 hours later,
how the temperature
drops to 10 below zero.
So people first get frozen,
they first get cold and then
they become a hypothermic.
So that a response time is,
is really an important issue.
Uh,
within the Adirondacks,
they decided to remove the ranger
cabins from the interior and instead a,
a higher,
more rangers that a would have a more,
uh,
requirements for patrolling
the interior area come.
An interesting trade off between,
between,
uh,
a response time.
And,
uh,
the,
the wilderness character of the area are
also really interesting debates about
how to manage fire and
wild lands and these very,
uh,
agency to agency.
So the forest service has a very
different policy toward a managing,
managing fires.
And,
uh,
the national park service has had,
and,
uh,
this was very apparent in the,
enormous Yellowstone national park fires,
uh,
that,
burned,
uh,
tens of thousands of acres.
So imagine the national parks service
lying next to us forest service land and
the park service has a no burn policy.
You know,
let nature take its course.
Lightening Strikes,
uh,
the,
the fire starts and,
uh,
we're not going to suppress it.
So what that meant to the forest service
was that their timber leases were quite
vulnerable and the timber companies
were claiming they had private property
rights to those,
uh,
timber and a,
the government had an
obligation to ensure that a,
it fought forest fires and,
uh,
to the best of their ability
to protect their rights.
So very interesting conflicts over,
over,
uh,
attitudes about,
how to manage a wilderness,
how to minutes nature,
and it's wild or form.
Uh,
and once you,
once you a permit,
a commodity such as as a,
uh,
a timber REIT or a,
a hunting right or a mineral extraction,
right,
then in a way government becomes obligated
to ensure continued access to the
corporation to get those rights
out of the public domain,
like you to think about.
A couple of other ideas
about property rights,
uh,
and,
we're almost running out of time.
And I'm going to give you a,
just this one example here of
development in the coastal zone.
This is a track of land that lies between
Los Angeles and Diego on the Pacific.
And here you see basically a,
uh,
a,
a planned unit development area,
uh,
where you have gated communities in the,
in the hills overlooking the Pacific
and they basically ran out of land.
So you can imagine if you have,
if you've got a,
a town and you a lay a grid over it
that is a one acre zoning and the entire
town,
no,
eventually you're going to have one
house on every one of those acres.
And that a is then thought of as a
concept of build out a town has added to
build out.
So if that is the case and
what are you going to do?
I mean,
I suppose you could allow people,
uh,
through a variance to a
zoning ordinance to build up,
uh,
to build higher structures.
But in this case that granted a developer,
the right to build a marina.
Now a marina,
what's up marina?
Well,
this is some marina.
Uh,
this marina has hundreds and
hundreds of bursts and these,
these boats are not a minor minor boats.
And a,
you can think about this one community,
uh,
to,
and,
and think about the process.
The developer goes to the state of
California because the California coastal
commission has jurisdiction.
It goes to the town of Dana Point.
It eventually it has to go to the,
the,
uh,
the coast guard and to a variety of
other federal agencies to get permits to
develop this.
But once they do that,
it creates an enormous,
uh,
enormously profitable business.
Uh,
not only do do these people
I have to pay slip fees,
uh,
but they have to pay fees
for having their sewage,
uh,
pumped out of their boats.
Uh,
they,
the town put up,
uh,
recreational opportunities that,
the the users will pay for.
Uh,
and the tax revenues to the community
are in the millions of dollars per year
because they,
the community is able to
tax the value of the boat.
Some of these boats are a 40,
50,
a 70 feet in length.
So that,
uh,
the,
the average estimate of real estate value,
uh,
you know,
the boats are always changing
depending upon who buys a Elise to,
to the,
uh,
the burst.
But about $250 million in
increased real estate value,
uh,
was created out of what was formerly
public land common land owned by and
managed by the state of California.
So I'm going to leave you
just with a thought that,
uh,
you know,
managing land,
uh,
is all about managing property rights and,
conflicts over access to scarce and
valuable resources and the Adirondacks,
uh,
provides.
I think one pretty
interesting example of that.
Uh,
because of the complexity of land
classifications that were created,
I tend to think of the Adirondacks,
uh,
as having a dramatically
shifted my perception of,
uh,
the potential for us on earth any
longer to experience wildness.
My idea of wildness is not what,
it was.
A,
when I worked there,
I had no understanding of
the chemical dimension of,
of the Adirondacks and how humans
have changed the chemistry of,
of the park.
And also raises a very interesting
question about climate change.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
Melinda Smith professor in ecology
and evolutionary biology gave a very
interesting lecture yesterday about the
influence of increasing temperature and,
uh,
changes in moisture on,
on,
uh,
the future of grasslands.
And she argued that,
uh,
will 3% of the world's grasslands
are now in protected area status.
Only 3%.
However,
changes in the humidity changes in the
temperature are causing reductions in
productivity and changes in biological
diversity that we're never imagined when
these legal regime,
such as the Adirondack
park agency were created.
Now in the Adirondacks,
you've got also changes in
temperature and you've got changes in,
in biological diversity.
And what that means is that the approach
to managing these property rights,
uh,
has been insufficient to manage
the ecological change that it's now
experiencing.
So it's dramatically shifting
my perception of what they,
uh,
the,
the future of a parking protected areas
should be as ecological systems and
habitats are literally migrating through,
uh,
these different parks and protected areas.
So what this means really is that a to,
to tackle,
uh,
if we have the objective of managing
biological diversity in parks,
that we really need to
think more closely about.
It's linked to climate change,
so that a regulatory regime that manages
climate is really essential for a
longterm effective management
of biological diversity.
So that's it for today.
Have a great weekend.